Let's go to our caller from the eight oh five
area code eight oh five eight oh five.
Are you there?
Hi.
Hey, who's this?
I think that might be me.
It is awesome by, um, appreciate your show.
You're pretty cool.
Um, I had a question about this whole ad pocalypse
thing that people are talking about.
Um, it seems like everyone wants to treat
these platforms as if they're actually the
public square when they're not beholden to
anybody but shareholders and advertisers.
That's correct.
Currently they're not.
Right.
And so I, I kinda don't get how, I guess everyone
wants it to be that and expects it to be this
neutral platform, but can anyone really pretend
that they are?
Here's the thing here.
So here, here's my take and not everybody's
take is the same on this.
For me it is unquestionable that right now
Twitter, Facebook, youtube, whoever can have
terms and conditions that restrict the types
of speech that is either allowed or monetize
bubble like there's no debate whatsoever that
as the law currently stands, they can do that.
What there's a debate about is should the
law around the regulation of these companies
be changed to consider them public accommodations?
In which case they would not be able to have
terms and conditions that restrict speech
beyond just what is illegal, what is called,
you know, what is calling for illegal activity
or whatever.
That's the debate.
You're completely right that as it stands
right now, like the entire ad apocalypse thing
is because youtube doesn't want to lose money
and they're going to make decisions that aren't
actually based on like the political leanings
of individuals who are reviewing content.
It's just based on what is going to prevent
brands from freaking out and pulling out ad
money.
If you want to change that, you need to designate
these platforms, public accommodations and
regulate them as such.
Cause the, that makes a lot of sense.
But it seems like introducing regulations
that would allow for any kind of speech as
it is, you know, just speaking out in the
world that what would happen is brands are
going to be freaked out anyway, even if it's
illegal.
They don't want to be associated with, you
know, potentially hateful speech for example.
So it seems like that could be the end almost
of that public square just by virtue of it's
the problem of that the business model being
so dependent on ads that can be attacked for
any particular, it doesn't matter what side
of the political spectrum someone's getting
attacked from.
Yes.
Just the ads don't want to be around it.
That's exactly right.
And in fact, my commentary on today's Program
says that, which is that I am on the left,
but I don't need to take a partisan approach
to realize that this is just about what's
going to freak brands out or not period.
And we ideally should sever this relationship
between the media producer and needing the
advertiser to be comfortable with their content.
And the way to do that is, is a, is direct
support.
I'm sorry, I'm at a time I gotta run.
I got, I'm going to let you go.
We, I wish we had more time to devote to that,
but I am going to talk about that more on
the
program that does it for calls today.
Sorry to everybody I didn't get to, but there
will be plenty of opportunities next week
to take more phone calls and drip from more
people.